is there something about this time where
even like world war three which has been
throwing around very casually
concerningly so even that the new cycle
wipes that away yeah well I I think we
have this
this General problem that we can't make
certain information even
you know
unequivocally certain information
emotionally
Salient like like we we respond quite
readily to certain things I mean as we
talked about we we respond to the
the little girl who fell down a well I
mean that just that gets 100 of our
emotional resources but
the abstract probability that of nuclear
war right even a high probability even
just even an intolerable probability
even if we put it at
30 percent right you know like it's just
like that's
Russian roulette with a you know gun
with three chambers and you know it's
aimed at the heads not only your head
but your kid's head and everyone's kid's
head and it's just 24 hours a day and
um
I mean I think people who who this
pre-ukraine I think the people who have
made it their business to
you know professionally to think about
the risk of nuclear war and to mitigate
it you know people like Graham Allison
or William Perry or
I mean I think they were putting like
the the ongoing risk I mean just the
risk that we're going to have if a
proper nuclear war at some point in the
you know the Next Generation
people were putting it at you know
something like 50 right they were living
with this sort of Damocles over our
heads now you might wonder whether
anyone could have reliable intuitions
about the probability of that kind of
thing but
the the status quo is truly alarming I
mean we've got you know we've got icbms
on Leaf aside smaller exchanges and you
know tactical nukes and how that could
how we could have a World War
you know based on you know incremental
changes we've got
the biggest bombs aimed at the biggest
cities in both directions
and it's old technology right and it's
you know and it's
vulnerable to some lunatic deciding to
launch or or misreading you know bad
data and we know we've been saved from
nuclear war
um
I think at least twice by
you know Soviet submarine commanders
deciding I'm not going to pass this up
to change a chain of command right it's
like this is
there's almost certainly an error and it
turns out it was an error it's like like
and we we need people
to I mean in that particular case like
he saw I think it was five
what seemed like five missiles launched
from the US to Russia and he reasoned if
the if America was going to engage in a
first strike they'd launch more than
five missiles right so this this has to
be fictional and then he waited long
enough to decide that it was fictional
but the probability of
a nuclear war Happening by mistake or in
some other species of inadvertence you
know misunderstanding uh
a technical malfunction
that's intolerable forget about the the
intentional use of it by by people who
are you know
Driven Crazy by some ideology uh and
more and more Technologies are enable
the kind of scale of Destruction and
misinformation plays into this picture
in a way that is
especially scary I mean once you can get
a deep fake of
you know the any current president of
the United States claiming to have
launched a first strike you know and
just
you know send that everywhere but that
can change the nature of Truth and then
we that might change the
um the engine we have for skepticism
is sharpen it
the more you definitely might have ai
and and digital watermarks that help us
maybe we'll not trust any information
that hasn't come through
uh specific channels right I mean so
like in in my world
it's like
I I no longer feel the the need to resp
you know respond to anything other than
what I put out in in my channels of
information it's like there's there's so
much there are so many people who have
clipped stuff of me that shows the
opposite of what I was actually saying
in context I mean the people have like
re-edited my podcast audio to make it
seem like I said the opposite of what I
was saying it's like unless I put it out
you know you can't be sure that I
actually said it you know I mean it's
it's just uh
but I don't know what it's like to live
like that for all forms of information
and uh I mean Strangely I think it may
require a
a greater siloin of information in the
end you know it's like it it it's uh
we're living through this sort of wild
west period where everyone's got a
newsletter and everyone's got a Blog and
everyone's got an opinion but once you
can fake everything that might be a
greater value for expertise yeah for
experts but a more rigorous system for
identifying who the experts are yeah or
just or just knowing that you know it's
going to be an arms race to
authenticate information so it's like if
if you can never trust a photograph
yeah unless it has been vetted by Getty
Images
because only Getty Images has the
resources to to authenticate the
provenance of that photograph and then a
test that hasn't been meddled with by AI
um and again I don't even know if that's
technically possible and maybe whatever
the tools
available for this will be you know
commodified and and the cost will be
driven to zero so quickly that everyone
will be able to do it you know it could
be like encryption but and it would be
proven and tested most effectively first
of course as always in porn
yeah which is where most of human
innovation technology happens first